it's deeply disturbing you know this is  you know kind of a dark you know a dark  mark on our history you know the US has  I think I'd say a mark of a society and  its is how it treats the most vulnerable  and particularly children and this is a  very dark mark on our history and I  think that will be you know the way it's  written in the future you know that we  are taking vulnerable children and  forcibly separating them from their  parents and however the good the care is  that or our staff are striving to  provide it's still not the care of a  parent and anyone who's you know whether  they're a parent or a child know that  forcible separation from a parent of a  small child is one of the most horrific  things that can happen and we as a  country are you know are you know  complicit at some level in this process  and you know it's it's shameful